[Music]
in my quest to expose how american guns
are trafficked throughout mexico
i never expected to be headed out to sea
but as we move deeper into the waters
these smugglers break down their
operation
[Music]
the sea of cortez is over 700 miles long
but less than 100 miles wide that means
these smugglers can make the crossing in
less than three hours
completely bypassing the military
checkpoints set up
along mexico's highways right now
they say they're delivering more and
more guns to sonora
directly across the sea that's the same
heavily contested territory
that hector in mexicali is also sending
guns to
i think that's it i think we're going to
that beach over there
oh there are some guys there there are
some guys actually waiting at the beach
or at least one guy that i see now
and he's coming to greet the boat he's
all dressed in black with a mask as well
yeah they're anchoring right there so
this is it
[Music]
i'm told the man in black is another
buyer from sonora
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
none of this sounds like arming a
criminal organization
they are army for war
[Music]
mexicana
i'm told the buyer is from an affiliated
cartel
fighting to regain territory in sonora
he's picking up a fresh order
including a pair of customized handguns
for rich narcos who don't just want a
weapon
they want to make a statement
sales like this are common for these
smugglers the market for american
assault rifles
is exploding
so they had 200 ak-47s cuerno de chivo
which is what they call them here
come through here in san felipe in just
one day last weekend
here's where things get interesting
remember when i said that you never
asked what cartel someone belongs to
i didn't this guy just decided to tell
me that he works for one of the fastest
growing mafias in mexico
the jalisco cartel also known as cjng
the organization is only about 10 years
old but aggressive maneuvers
and terrifying isis-style executions
have helped them dominate
underworld markets across mexico
becoming the sinaloa cartel's
biggest rival and the kingpin of these
violent upstarts
perhaps the most dangerous drug lord in
the world
is known as el mencho
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
you